I couldn't wait to grow a beard I felt
like that was a true marker of what it
meant to be a man in part probably
because my dad had a beard and aren't we
all just trying to be our dads
growing up you always like question your
masculinity
I've definitely questioned my gender
before I've always felt like a man not
sure I've always been like a manly man I
have been made to feel less than a man
for a good chunk of my life I started
really questioning whether I was or not
I tried a fantasy football I'm bad at I
hate it but I felt like if I didn't
participate in my school's fantasy
football group that I wasn't a dude
I had this Kingston lunchbox that that I
really liked it's made fun of it both
boys and girl told me that I shouldn't
have that and so that was the last time
I ever used that lunchbox my
girlfriend's dad said I wasn't a real
man when he said that he was referring
to the fact that he didn't think I could
be the man of the house if I were to
marry his daughter you know it's those
microaggressions and macro aggressions
that constantly worry they start making
you question your your right to be
called a man different points of my life
I've been self-conscious of aspects of
myself physically because I felt like it
was an indication that I wasn't man
enough growing up with skinny kid like
defin fault a little weaker as a short
guy everyone has remarked at how small I
am I'm kind of skinny and lanky and
awkward if I could change the part of my
body I definitely add some muscle mass
because muscles make a man a muscular
man with the six-pack is an ideal my
physical form I've worked really hard
for it to look this way getting stronger
is amazing the muscles are in the form
the look the confidence a real man I
guess is anyone that identifies as a man
that does not imaginary if you take away
all these societal expectations protects
women take up a lot of space to be tough
can't cry cannot be gay you really don't
have anything else besides just someone
that identifies as a guy because when we
think to polemically about what makes a
man or what makes a woman we erase all
of the like giant space of what makes a
person